adil ltr' a renowned surgeon with many
years experience in the National Health
Service Donna Campbell a healthcare
support worker who could light up a room
with her infectious laugh just some of
the UK health and care workers who've
lost their lives to kovat 19 often for
want of proper protective equipment my
basic understanding of infectious
disease is increased exposure equals
increased risk of contracting that
disease and as key workers as health
care workers particularly we are at
increased risk of exposure because we
are working with people who have current
virus every single day and without the
right protective equipment then there
will be people who die because of being
at work every doctor is a nonprofit
organization run by doctors campaigning
to keep health workers safe as well as
highlighting how far behind other
countries the UK is in the provision of
protective equipment or PPE every doctor
hears daily from medical staff forced to
use improvised methods to keep
themselves safe this is happening months
after concerns about coronavirus were
first raised by health workers in the UK
and despite repeated government promises
that items of PPE have been procured in
their hundreds of millions and are being
widely distributed as Britain nears the
peak of its epidemic dangerous gaps
remain well I'm sorry if people feel
that there have been failings I'll be
very very clear about that but at the
same time we are in an unprecedented
global health pandemic right now critics
called the Home Secretary's apology
half-hearted and the public services
Union unison says the time for excuses
has passed we're continuing to see
significant problems with the supply of
PPE in social care social care staff are
still telling us that and there are
major shortages we've had some members
telling us the employees are refusing to
let them wear face masks
to help close the gaps this group of
london-based
entrepreneurs has pitched in 3d printing
visors for NHS hospital staff I was
inspired by one very sad story about
Norfolk Park nurses who using bin bags
to protect themselves so using 3d
printers behind us
'we were to manufacture this face shield
the face shield can be 3d printed in
just under two hours
and using just some simple elastic and
acetate sheet that has been laser-cut we
can ship these out directly to hospitals
that desperately need them there will be
a time for answers time to ask who
failed how and when but for now there is
only reality to cope with health workers
in hospitals and care homes across the
country short of basic protection as
they tend to the sick and the dying and
in some cases having to decide whether
saving a life is worth jeopardizing
their own Jonah hull al Jazeera at
London